hello everyone and welcome to the final
and the most important round of
defeaths.com grand swiss uh it's a
grigori operin a russian grandmaster
versus alireza firuja who is leading the
tournament and
well basically he only needs a draw to
qualify for the tournament but if he
wins the game uh he could also easily
win the win the entire tournament
although when the
uh you know a spot in the candidates is
on the line you don't really care all
that much about winning the tournament
or you know gaining a a few rating
points uh even uh though after alireza's
yesterday's win uh against the david
howell he again reclaims the world
number four spot uh in front of yani
pomishi uh but uh grigori operin also
has a chance to qualify for the
candidates and he's a very very tough
opponent uh so far he has not lost a
single game furuja as you've seen uh
has lost that one to fabiana carwana but
uh also oppani did not face fabi in this
tournament because he started very slow
he had got quite a lot of draws and then
he started piling up wins uh so he
avoided fabi yeah in the entire
tournament uh but uh in order uh for you
two guys to really understand this here
are some of the things that could happen
so who will qualify for the candidates
this is a graphic from the from the
official stream so if boards one and two
draw and white wins the rest of the
games uh alireza and fabi will qualify
for the candidates if boards wanted to
draw black wins the other games then
alireza and grigorio operand here
qualify for the candidates um uh you see
the difference in bucholtz with carolina
is half a point and if furuja and predk
wins uh then boards uh three to seven or
in boards three to seven old rose then
firuja and alexander prietka qualify uh
for the uh feed a candidates tournament
and these are only some
of the approximations there are more of
them but these are obviously the
the most possible ones so that being
said let's see what happens here and how
will uh they both approach this game so
operon could really use a win and
alireza
is very very happy with a draw so
opening with the white pieces opens with
e4 with e5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and
the bishop to b5 opening goes for the
real lopez and what do you play when you
absolutely
have to not lose the game uh knight to
f6 of course all it is goes for the
berlin defense we have d3
no quick drawish lines here we want to
play an actual game bishop to c5 and now
bishop captures in c6 we have d captures
and opening castles
and now we often have this position if
you've been following what's been
happening in the chess world that we um
we have this quite a lot and you have to
defend the e5 point and you can do this
in a variety of ways you can play queen
e7 to defend it you can play bishop back
to d6 to defend it you could bring the
knights to d7 to defend it you could
also pin the white knight with bishop to
g4 so these are all viable options
alireza chooses knight to d7 and now we
have c3 preparing to strike in the
center with d4 we have castles and now
d4 so nothing new here this has all been
played before
the e5 pawn is also attacked twice so
bishop d6 nicely defends it and now
bishop the g5 attacking the queen here
so f6 defending uh this is one of the uh
a
few uh rare occasions where it's
actually okay to play f6 uh bishop to h4
and now queen to e8 so now we're we have
one pin we're going to put our queen to
f7 and we're gonna have a very very
enjoyable position so knight b to d2 uh
and now opening is uh
sort of playing uh a bit of uh uh mind
games here because uh alireza had this
position himself with the white pieces
against dmitry and draken in the 2019
world blitz championship uh and the
queen to e6 was played here
by uh by akin and alireza won that game
very nicely but here uh even though
there are a couple of other moves for
example queen here is uh he's a normal
queen to f7 is a normal knight the b6 is
a known move now it is a place a5 and it
is now already as of 11 that we have a
completely new game he wants to get uh
some um pawn moves on the queen side
maybe a four b5 then get the knight to
b6 and have a very nice game
uh so what can you do here queen to c2
white just continues development connect
his rooks and now preparing maybe
knights the c4 to go after this bishop
so queen to f7 now stopping knight to c4
and also putting some pressure on this
a2 pawn if this rook is ever centralized
uh well you're going to lose that a2
pawn so bishop back to g3 and now comes
a4 and up until this point all of the
moves were pretty pretty much blitzed
out from uh operand's perspective uh
alireza did spend some time uh and here
is the first time that uh operin started
thinking and he spent some 10 minutes on
his next move you have to decide whether
b3
is a good option here uh because if you
play something like rook after e1 then
maybe c5 comes in if d5 b5 and then
black got pretty much what he wanted out
of the position so open and tries b3 now
the c4 square is defended and you are
ready to bring this knight to c4 and uh
you could always capture here and trade
off everything for example captures
captures captures and captures but you
can always do this so it's not something
you need to rush so instead after b3 we
have e captures on d4 by alireza knight
to c4 was coming and you do not want to
trade bishop for knight you want to
trade the bishop for bishop if possible
also made after some uh 15 minutes of
thinking so here we have bishop captures
and b6 c captures and now knight
captures on d4 again you have to decide
between captures with the bishop and
captures with opponent captures with the
knight
both you know have their merits um uh
operating decides to capture with the
knight and now uh you are trying to play
against this d6 pawn for the moment at
some point otherwise i can probably just
push d5 and trade it off but uh still
even though if this happens we can play
captures captures again there will be
this d5 pawn uh that the white can
attack the knight is a great blockading
piece so if the pawn is ever on d5 we're
going to pile up on it and only now
alireza traits here we have captures
captures rook captures on a1 rook
captures on a1 and now d5 so
there's nothing better it's it's a very
solid position uh you you play the
berlin defense if white doesn't try uh
you know first for something crazy uh
you know you can't really expect uh you
know things to be flying all over the
place so e captures on the e5 and now
not c captures but rather queen captures
of course nicely centralizing the queen
and now we have two pawns each here and
alireza still has a bishop so if the
position opens up and this bishop gains
some momentum could be very dangerous
but the knights are also very impressive
so knight to c4
we have knights to e5 offering a trade
here and you don't really gain anything
by trading if you just capture for
example if captures you attack the
knight knight f3 for example bishop to
g4 not just threatening to win a lot of
material and for example knight here you
can play rook d8 and you've solved all
of black's problems black has a very
very enjoyable position now so we have
knight to b6 by opening going after the
queen here queen back to d8 attacking
the knight and now knight captures on c8
so opening decides that the bishop if it
comes alive could be
a very formidable piece so queen
captures on c8 and now knight to f5 and
now we have this beautiful knight here
of course you're threatening knight to
e7 check to win the queen
and uh it's not easy to kick it away
from there g6 while it can be played at
some point is
basically a weakening of your king's
position so first just queen to e6 uh
keeping the queen centralized and now
rook to d1 if you go for something like
rook to a7 which is always a very nice
idea you know you want to bring your
rook to the seventh rank we're just
going to kick the knight away and now
you have to calculate whether this is
possible for white because if it is you
don't want to play that but it's
perfectly fine for example even if we we
go for something like this
the black king is perfectly safe here
let's say queen d2 check you can just
play g5 and now if queen c2 going for
some like queen captures on h7 just
knight g6 and white has no compensation
for the sacrificed p so what would
happen if g6 is played probably
something like knight back to d4
attacking the queen queen d5 and the
black is perfectly fine here you can
never capture on b7 uh if you do just c5
and black wins so uh no hope there so
instead of going for this very nice rook
lift the rook is re-maneuvered over to
d1 now the d6 square is looking very
nice for for white's pieces and aladeza
just brings the knight back knight to f7
uh the d6 square is guarded knight to d4
attacking the queen queen to e7 and here
knight to f5 uh and he was uh in fact in
this position on move 26 that uh
grigorio and alireza furuja agreed to a
draw
as there is nothing more uh to be done
here
so uh and what what this means for for
the tournament standings is that alireza
uh we don't know if he won the
tournament yet but we do know that he
qualified for the feed a candidates
tournament 2022
and that is uh well that's an incredibly
impressive achievement um so we'll see
uh we'll see who who will be the next
one to qualify uh fabi has excellent
chances if he wins his game even if he
draws he still has excellent chances but
we're going to discuss that in the
in the other game that uh fab is
currently playing against yu yangi
so incredible achievement for for
alireza uh at 18 years old uh he
qualifies for for the candidates
tournament it's gonna be it's gonna be
incredible and it would be it would be a
shame of course it would be a shame for
many strong players not to qualify but
fob is world number two and you know you
you can't expect fabi if he's not if
he's not the challenger for for the
title at least he should maybe be in the
candidates tournament uh so we'll see
what happens we're going to discuss all
the other options in some other games we
show but yeah just wanted to you know
brief you guys in alireza has qualified
for the feed a candidates tournament
2022
inform your friends at the bar in the
library
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it berlin defense uh you
know never fails when you when you you
know just need to be safe i would like
to thank uh sasan faiz alessandro atura
tom deralon micah kennedy and david
kimura for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing with the coverage of this
exciting event checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day